It's hard to tell from that picture cause he's an actual one 85 right there.
Very,
very deflated.
It's amazing the difference between some guys like when they weigh in like,
Yo,
well when he weighs in at one 85,
he's still looks so perv ridiculous.
Uber jacked at one 85.
You can't believe he only weighs one 85 against them some scale then.
But then he fucking blew up.
I mean he just puts all that meat back on your boy,
your boy.
A Whitaker was like that mother fuckers.
Here's interviews.
Like I said,
it was magic.
He's like,
it's magic.
See that mango from that to that.
And he goes,
honestly,
find them before and he's aging and this time he was even harder.
He's like,
something's up their son.
Yeah.
Um,
here's the thing.
May Be,
but you know what else may be may be crazy.
Cuban genetics.
I think that shit would be crazy.
There's young genetics.
How much more impressive whether whatever it is on,
let's say is on something,
whether it could beat him twice.
Yeah.
There should not be a third fight.
I don't think this decision was just in the second fight.
Now you're crazy.
But I think there should have been 10 eights.
No,
I think the new rules I think should have been a draw of that.
I don't think you'll all won that fight if any.
If you're going to give you all a ten eight then that's a draw draw.
I'm fine and I don't think they give draws out enough.
I will draw the finder because then they're forced to have that trust.
What I'm saying that I'm fine with.
I didn't think that a decision.
I thought like there's too many moments in the fight where yo well hurt Whitaker
like really hurt.
There was no moments in the fight where Whitaker really hurt you.
Well like really hurt him.
Like had them in deep trouble.
There was one but that head kick,
the wobbling a little bit of [inaudible] on Thursday.
The head cake was when Dow,
I don't think that even fucking did much if wobble his legs a tad bit.
But if you go round by round,
watch that fight a bunch.
I think I have,
which was a good,
that was he landed with the foot,
right,
like and hit in the face,
top of the head,
but also like you'll round by round.
I just stylistically I had Whitaker winning three two.
All right.
Let's say I gave you out when he fucked him up that night.
There was a fourth of fifth in first was both rounds.
You had got in trouble.
I gave one to ten nine to you all and then if you give a ten eight it would
still be a draw,
which I'm fine with,
which makes more sense to me,
but I,
it's just people have a hard time with decisions when the guy at the end of the
fight is fucking the guy up.
Now obviously this is coming from someone who's a professional commentator,
so I understand this is a ridiculous argument,
but the ridiculous argument is if we're going to judge what a fight is,
we all know if you're watching a fight fight,
right?
If you and I are in a fight and you're on top of me beating the shit out of me
in the last few seconds when the cops come in,
that doesn't matter if I,
if I've ran around this room and kicked your legs for the first two minutes and
then you've got on top of me and we're beating the fuck out of me for the last
20 seconds when the cops can talk in prison rules won the fight.
He won the fight in the fight,
but as a professional sport stamp.
But this is a professional sport that's kind of a fight.
It's not just a box that's the box.
And if I win the first eight rounds,
right,
and you're whooping my ass,
nine 10 1112 areas,
first day,
what do we do there it is right?
It's a good no,
it's a real good point,
dude.
It's a real good point.
But the idea is to see that didn't hurt.
He was on wobbled.
He was already tired.
Dude,
look how wobbly he is already there.
How about the kicks by fucking Whitaker tickers?
So good dude.
And the fact that he fought that fight,
most of it with a fucking broken hand.
He's even with one's brown and being with one,
like the first fight.
Come on now.
He's phenomenal.
He through that hand to even went,
oh look,
he got in trouble for sure couple times.
I had one round of 10 eights that'd be a draw.
See this right here.
This is a ten eight man.
This is a ten eight again,
even if you give a ten eight it's still,
it should be a draw.
Then maybe he wouldn't win the fight.
He would draw.
Two guys are fighting.
It's a close round,
but one guy drops the route,
drops him.
It has him hurt.
They're like everything up until that moment,
his close,
I think that's still a ten eight gs and toss and ten eight 10 eights.
It's gotta be the differences.
Someone almost got finished.
This is an almost got finished moment.
The legs go,
the person falls,
the guy gets on top,
guards pounded them to see,
I don't have a problem with ten nine nine I think has to be a clear fucking
bully beat down for ten eight I think that should be a ten seven I think we
should make the shit make sense.
Game.
I've been fighting,
fighting 10 set.
You gotta stop,
Bro.
I really feel like this,
this scorecard,
this,
this 10 point must system is silly.
The whole thing is silly.
The judging,
but the silliness.
Yeah,
you're right.
We've been,
we've kicked that fucking whore.
The numbers.
Like why do we need 10 points?
Just because boxing always had 10 points there.
You don't want to use in their hands.
They're not even using their elbows.
You know?
Just think about all the different things.
Like how,
what Swarthmore is a jab worth more than an elbow.
Yeah.
What's worth more a guillotine choke that you get out of how much?
How many points do you get for that?
I've got to figure that out,
man.